Hi, my name is Rob Phillips and I'm from Caltech. And I'm
here at the Marine Biological Laboratory in Woods Hole. And
I was here to record another iBio event in a certain sense, and
we thought it would be a great opportunity to take advantage
of the fact that I'm here with my mom on her 80th birthday.
And so, what we're going to do is talk about our joint family
adventure as I worked my way through science and I think
it will probably be interesting to people, since as you're going to find out,
it was a bit of a wild adventure and it required a huge
amount of parental support. So I thought I would just start
out with an easy question that I think all the listeners
are really dying to know, which is what was your best
birthday present ever?
You! Of course.
How's that work?
That works just fine. Perfect.
So all kidding aside, so what we're going to do is maybe just take
a little bit of a travel through the years, say between 9th grade,
I guess, which is when I got a D in algebra, to maybe
when I got my job at Brown University, which was the
end of our financial dependence on you guys, which is when I
was 33 years old. So you know, that's hard.
We grew up in a house full of books and I've always been a
great reader. I'm kind of curious what you think the role of books was
in our upbringing and also in all 3 of us, there's 3 kids,
and all of us are big readers.
Well I think it started when you were all young, and I read you,
each of you, every single night. Even sometimes when we went out
before sitters. So I was always a reader, my parents
were always readers, and obviously books were hugely
important to me personally. And I could tell from reading to
you, that you really enjoyed it and you took up books in a
big way. And it was something we shared, and I wanted to
just inject something, what a thrill it was for me to see when you
had your two children, how you would read to them every
night. And sometimes when I would be visiting you, even when
Casey was old enough certainly to read, when he was probably
13 or something. You two were reading the trilogy..
Yeah, Tolkien.
Tolkien trilogy.
We also read Haroun and the Sea of Stories from uh..
Right, so I thought, this is something that just went on.
So obviously, we were big into books. I also remember going to
lots of used bookstores with you.
Right, I was going to come to that. So by April 30th, 1997,
that's a Saturday, which is the day that I discovered that I was
going to do science. When I was given a lecture about how
Eratosthenes figured out the radius of the Earth. And in a
nutshell, somebody could tell me the radius of the Earth
but in a nutshell, what I learned was this clever guy measured
the radius of the Earth by looking at the shadow of the
noon day sun in two different places on the Earth and
knowing the distance between the two places. And that
endows this question of realism, because it shows you how
trigonometry, geometry, clever thinking, optics, you know all these
things get merged. And above all, what it shows is that science
is a relationship between one person and nature.
There's no authorities. I don't like authorities. There's
no books. There's no rules. There's no regulations.
It's just you and your question. That's what Eratosthenes
was. That's what blew my mind. Before that, I thought
science as kind of stupid, because I thought it was a bunch of
memorization of facts, like French kings, you know. I thought
science was like that. The next morning, I told you and dad
that I was going to do science. And also told you I wasn't
gonna go to college, that I was going to leave high school
after 11th grade. On books, do you remember right after
that, you and I went up to LA and we went used book shopping?
Yes we did -- And we came back with like, 200 books. I
was just curious if you had anything to say, why did you do that?
And what was your take on that?  -- Because it was fun!
Because we were together and we were doing our book thing.
And I was always amazed because you were after books
I knew nothing about, all these theoretical physics titles00:04:19.07]
that were just totally out of my range. And I could go and look
at the things I liked, which was fiction, nonfiction, whatever.
But wander around with you, which is great fun
to do that. What a kick!
Yeah, so in that April I was 16 years old. And three months later
I basically left high school after 11th grade with my degree
and shortly thereafter, one of my good friends, which I'm sure you remember
very well, was killed in an accident. And that really established
that I was no -- no way that I was going to go to college.
How does that relate? I mean, why does the death
-- which I know is a horribly sorrowful time, but why that?
Why not go to college?
Yeah, I don't know if you remember. But I had a poster
in my room of Jack London, and it's a picture of him on
his boat, and it said "I would rather be ashes than dust." And
it talks about being a fiery meteor, rather than a sleepy
planet or something like that. And I just read Irving Stone's book,
Jack London: His Life, Sailor on Horseback. So it was the
juxtaposition of that book which showed me the life of Jack London,
which was really so amazing. And then seeing the death of Lance
at age 17, you know, he was snuffed out. And it made me realize,
you know, today's kind of a good day to think about it, it's
a birthday. At this point, I've reached an age where birthdays
I find kind of sad, rather than happy days. Just in a certain
sense. And it's because you realize that life is short.
And it just flies by. And then if you're unlucky, like Lance was,
you can just have your life snubbed out. And what I felt
is that, you know, is going to college was just what you were supposed
to do. And I guess I just felt that life is short, I better not do
what I'm supposed to do. And I should do what I should do.
I just felt that I did not want to cave and just go off to UCSB
for no reason. I would've just lived in Isla Vista
and just gone to some stupid classes.
Why did you even get to the point where you went up there,
where you decided to go, where you got an apartment..
Because you and dad insisted that you would let me do my deal
if I got into a UC school. So I got into a UC school.
Are you satisfied? So I got in and that was good enough.
Then I had satisfied the parental requirement, but I had no
interest in going to UCSB or anywhere else. So I didn't.
Well, I left home at 17. I moved up to LA shortly, but
the real thing that happened was I went off on a boat.
I sailed 3000 miles. And what I wanted to ask you about,
has in a certain sense to do with how I feel about my kids
and the adventures they have. I was 17 when I left the port
at Harbor Island on that boat. And I'm kind of curious, you know,
we set off. There was no cell phones, I didn't talk to you for three months.
I sent home stupid letters that came by snail mail. I'm curious about
parental fear in the face of adventure. Because there was lots of it
that we might touch on, but what did you and dad have to say
about, you know, these things that were ostensibly scary?
And I remember when you -- standing there watching you,
literally sail away. And of course, I was all teary and I thought
-- I think maybe I was just stupid and I didn't realize how
much could happen. I was also amazed at the letters that you
wrote home. Because you were reading all of Shakespeare,
as I recall. Trying to go through it one at a time. And commenting
on that. Commenting on what you were seeing and feeling.
Although, we have to be honest, they were incredibly
embarrassingly pretentious. I mean, I was trying out
my Shakespearean vocabulary and looked like a moron.
I know, but as a mom, it's okay.
Because I thought, here's a kid who's really going out there,
because once you told us, and you told us the day that you
were supposed to -- and we were going to get into the car and drive you
to Santa Barbara that you were not going to college,
right then is when you think, is this really going to work or not?
Are you really going to make a life for yourself? When did you
-- when you finally said, okay, I'm going to go. I'm going to take courses
now through the University of Minnesota. What brought that on you?
So now I'm going to go back, I'm going to have to go back
and do something rather more traditional, in order to do
what I think I want to do.
So first of all, let's remind you and me, that was 6 years
after high school. In that intervening 6 years, you know, I worked
at a computer store, I worked at Alpha Microsystems and repaired
hard disk drives, went on an 18,000 mile trip, I took 6 months,
I was an electrician for 4 years, I crawled around in attics
in Santa Barbara and La Jolla. And I was studying all
the time. And what happened was, I was on a 3 month trip to Europe,
and I was sitting on a train. And a guy from Westinghouse,
an executive was sitting next to me, his name was Donald
Trexler. I met him once in my life, and he told me I was an idiot.
I basically told him that I had a resume that said I had read
this and that book, and I had learned this and that physics,
and so on. And I said I sent it to Beckman Instruments and
all these places, and they basically didn't even answer me.
And he said, well, you're an idiot. Go get your union card.
So what happened was, I came back to San Diego and I
went to the UCSD library and I found this book called, How to
Get a College Degree Without Going to College.
And there were four universities I found that had these
sort of university without walls programs, where you could earn
a degree without going to college. Because I just think that
I'm not suited -- I mean, I'm a failure as a classroom student.
You know, I don't like tests, I don't like the notion of one person
telling other people what they're supposed to know.
That's interesting. I don't remember the gentleman's story
on the train. That's really interesting. So that's really what
-- That's really what happened. And then, the connection to
grad school is because Chuck Campbell, who was at
Minnesota. You know, everyone was kind of against him
admitting a physics student. But he said, let the guy fail.
And you know, to me, that's one of the main philosophies of life,
let people fail. Give them a chance to fail, because we're very
conservative. And I like to use sports analogies, you know all my
heroes in surfing and snowboarding, they pay. They pay with getting
hurt. And the reason is because they're right on the edge
And that's the kind of science that I like. So anyway, he said
let the guy fail. And after I talked to him, he said, you know
you should go to grad school. And I had no clue what grad school
was. None. And I said, okay, I'll try it out. And so I applied
and I got into some of the places, such as Wash U and UCSD. Yeah.
So you did.
Yeah. Plus, I mentioned at the beginning, until the age of 33,
we were still getting financial help from you and dad. So
I'm curious to hear your thoughts about the grad student
trajectory. You know, the hardship financially. And the
not knowing where you're going to get a job. You know,
lot of graduate students and postdocs, they go exactly through
what we went through. Where you wonder, am I going to get
a professorship? You remember, I interviewed on Wall Street.
So what are your thoughts about that?
Well, I think if you can manage it, obviously. You try to manage
it. It's your children, you want them to get the best you can
for them. So sure, it's not easy financially. I think even
more important is the wandering about in your case, where you
don't go in the traditional way. And I remember when you were trying
-- you were even getting your first postdoc, you saying something
like, oh they're going to want someone who went to Harvard,
who came up the traditional way. And I'd say, oh no, I'm sure things
will be alright. Not knowing, of course. But I had a great
-- I just thought you did a great job. I wasn't sure it was going to come, but
it's hard!
I would just say that there's a lot of emphasis on that.
The blue blood aspects, it does have a big effect on
things. What about parenting? I just like to a little bit come back to
these things of, you know, I'm thinking about the many
rough steps along the way. So you know, the -- I mentioned earlier
that Lance got killed, and you remember that his brother, Joe,
who was also my dear friend, drowned in the ocean
not too long after that. And again, some of these adventures,
the dangers, I guess I'm just -- I'm very curious to hear how
it played out. And I think you may remember a story from
Caltech. I'm not going to mention who the grad student was,
but you were visiting and one of my grad students made a remark
about how all this stuff that we're talking about now is actually me telling
stories about myself. And you bit his head off, because you
lived it. And again, this isn't about glorifying anything that happened,
it's actually quite the opposite. I'm still just very curious about
how I would've been quite fearful if I had been in your
boat. I'm not sure if I would've been able to handle it.
Having my kids do that.
I don't know how I handled it. I wasn't as fearful as I was
when I look back on it, I think, you know, I probably should've been
scared out of my mind. I think I took it rather well.
Yeah, there's no doubt about it.
About parenting, I think it's the one thing in life that nobody ever teaches
anyone. And it's something you -- it's just like trial and error.
You muddle through, you would know that, you muddle through.
But certainly, the way you went about living your life and starting
out on your trajectory was scary. And a lot of times I
was afraid and obviously when you were gone, I missed you
terribly. But as I say, I think you really showed rather quickly
that you were gonna make it.
The thing that's easy to take for granted and that's not obvious
I think to people is that there's a bit of nuance about how
these stories play out that have to do with the family
that surrounds you. And so, here at the MBL, I see people with
families and you can kind of  get a sense that, okay, that's somebody
where there's some magic going on in that household. And
you know, I've said it before, but this is a pretty great day.
Because it's your 80th birthday and it's my 54th birthday.
And yesterday was my daughter and your granddaughter's
birthday. It's a time for reflection, since we're all together.
And also, you know, I'm here as the director of the Physiology
course, which is a dream come true and an impossibility
to even 10 years ago even imagine that I would have that
privilege. And so, I guess what I would say about it is
that, you know, I would like the viewers to be aware
of it is that it took a lot of support. Financial support,
of course, but I'm not really talking about that. I'm talking about the
emotional, the psychological, the intellectual support
that you and dad gave all of us, but me especially
along this crazy adventure. And the adventure continues.
And our adventures continue together.
Let's hope.
Yeah, and I guess I'm looking forward having a nice rest of
today with you. And I love you very much.
I love you very much. I'm very proud of you. Very grateful.